With the single possible exception of Devil
Fruits, Swords are easily the single most
awesome and powerful things in all of One
Piece, so we are going to rank the 13 strongest
swords EVER in the story.
Starting with Trafalgar Law’s lethal blade,
Kikoku.
And while you might not expect this sword
to be ranked very high – especially with
that fluffy cross guard – it is actually
one the swords that has dealt the most damage
in the entire story.
And that’s because this extraordinary blade
has served Law in intense battles against
strong fighters Warlords and Emperors of the
Sea.
Plus, Law uses Kikoku in his strongest attacks,
like the super destructive Puncture Willie,
which even broke through an entire island.
We also know that this sword is cursed, which
means it was made by incredibly skilled craftsmen
and that it is nearly impossible for a weak
swordsman to use because they cannot control
the will of the blade.
But Law’s surgical blade of death is certainly
not the only cursed blade that we will see
in this ranking.
Now moving on from the Surgeon’s blade,
let’s discuss a sword owned by some one
who literally died.
At number twelve we have this skeleton’s
cane sword.
And Brook named this dapper blade Soul Solid,
mostly because he is able to combine his icy
cold soul powers to make this sword a devastating
weapon in combat.
And just like the previous sword, Soul Solid
has clashed with emperors like Big Mom and
it has never let Brook down in over 50 years
of graceful swordsmanship.
One more thing to mention about Soul Solid
is that it actually has a personality of its
own.
This is common with many swords, and the author
has even drawn Brook’s sword as a wrinkly
old woman.
But this sword is not even close to the insanely
powerful and famous blades later on in the
video.
Next in the ranking is one of the largest
swords ever used in the entire story.
No not this one or even this one – damn
I wish someone actually used this sword
– but no, now we have this enormous blade
. This is Funkfreed, and it is the only sword
in the entire story that actually ate a devil
fruit.
And because of this rare ability, it can actually
transform from its base sword form, a hybrid
snake-like blade, and a full elephant form
. Which is an absolutely insane power that
is completely wasted by the most pitiful character
in the entire story . Because all I’m saying
is that if this sword was used by an actually
strong character, it could be one of the best
swords because of its sheer versatility.
You’d basically never have to worry about
losing your sword because it could just transform
and come to you.
While the magnificent elephant sword made
a tremendous impression, the next sword has
been an important part of the story for nearly
1000 chapters.
Enter the Sandai Kitetsu which of course is
owned by the Roronoa Zoro.
He discovered this blade in chapter 97 at
a sword shop in Logue Town.
Initially, the shop owner refused to allow
anyone to take it because its previous owners
all died.
However, Zoro was determined to prove himself
and challenged the blade's curse.
And yes, this is yet another cursed blade
in our ranking.
But even after earning the sword, Zoro initially
struggles to control the Sandai Kitetsu’s
bloodlust.
This goes to show us that a swordsman using
a cursed blade must give extra focus to the
blade to prevent it from cutting things they
don't intend.
But that’s not all about this impressive
sword because in One Piece many swords are
actually ranked based on their exceptional
feats, remarkable craftsmanship, and sheer
power.
The Sandai Kitetsu is a simple graded blade,
which is the lowest of the swords that are
actually ranked.
Though I must add it is still way better than
most normal swords.
Then ranked above graded blades are 50 Skillful
Grade blades, 21 Great Grade blades, and finally
12 Supreme Grade blades.
Now, you may already know about the other
two Kitetsu blades.
Supposedly, the Sandai is the weakest of the
three, but I am going to exclude the Nidai
Kitetsu from this ranking since we have only
briefly glimpsed it in Wano.
Plus I actually believe that due to Zoro's
countless battles with the Sandai, it may
have already surpassed the Nidai Kitetsu in
strength.
Which yes, that is a thing.
Swords can actually get stronger in One Piece
based on their weilder’s haki, which we’ll
discuss more with some of the top ranked swords
later in the video.
While Sandai’s curse makes it a blade to
be feared, no sword on this ranking has more
personality than Big Mom’s Napoleon.
This massive hat-sword has been combined with
a piece of Big Mom’s soul to make it a living,
breathing creature.
It can grow to massive sizes and has clashed
with countless strong opponents, including
Kaido, meaning it has to be an incredibly
sturdy sword.
But even Napoleon hasn't achieved something
as impressive as this next blade, which managed
to leave a scar on Kaido.
This is Zoro's famous Wado Ichimonji, one
of the three swords he used to leave a bloody
wound on Kaido during their rooftop battle.
And this sword is the closest to Zoro’s
heart, since it also represents his promise
with his childhood friend to become the world’s
strongest swordsman.
But besides its historical significance, the
Wado Ichimonji is also one of the Twenty One
Great Grade Swords, making it one of the strongest
blades ever.
Many believe it to be Zoro's most important
sword since he's had it since he was a child.
And personally, I think he will make it even
stronger and it will become one of the highest-ranked
swords in the story.
All of that still doesn’t make it stronger
than the next blade on in this ranking, because
it has been around for hundreds of years and
was used by the literal sword god himself.
This is none other than Shusui, which belonged
to the legendary samurai Ryuma.
Zoro earned this blade after defeating the
zombie version of Ryuma, and even Zoro immediately
noticed that this blade was heavy and incredibly
powerful.
This sword is another of the 21 Great Grade
swords, but on top of that it is a legendary
Black Blade.
What is a Black Blade?
Well, that’s an excellent question.
There are only two of these Black Blades in
the entire story, and while we don’t know
exactly how this process works, we were told
that swords can become black blades after
countless battles alongside its master . Undoubtedly,
this involves ridiculously high levels of
haki.
Sadly, Zoro couldn’t keep Shusui forever
because in chapter 954 he was begged to return
it to Wano country because it is considered
a national treasure.
But Zoro wouldn’t give it up for free, and
he only agreed to do this in exchange for
another blade that we’ll discuss higher
in the rankings.
Then just outside of the top 5, we have the
infamous cursed sword, the Shodai Kitetsu.
This sword is the strongest of the Kitetsu
line and is the very first blade in this video
which owns the Supreme Grade Sword rank.
And while we have never officially seen this
blade in the story, a common theory is that
it is owned by this guy because it has an
extremely similar hilt, wrapping, and crossguard
to the other Kitetsu blades.
So clearly, just based on reputation, its
ranking, and its likely owner, this is going
to be an extremely powerful sword that I cannot
wait to actually see in action.
Which means that you should definitely, absolutely,
undoubtedly subscribe to the channel so you
don’t miss future videos discussing the
secrets of the One Piece world.
Then launching into the Top 5, we have a blade
that you may confuse for another famous character.
This is Ace , and this is also Ace . Which
would honestly get a bit confusing around
the house if they were alive, so parenting
tip #1, probably don’t name your child after
your favorite sword.
And if you want more one piece parenting tips,
make sure to subscribe to the channel.
But for a long time we wondered about the
famous sword of the former pirate king Gol
D. Roger.
Many fans believed that Roger gave his sword
to Shanks, but it turns out that this is a
completely different sword.
We also recently learned that it is one of
the 12 Supreme Grade blades in a visual book
written by the author.
And that makes a lot of sense because this
badass cutlass is Roger’s primary weapon
and he used it to fight the strongest characters
in the entire story.
However, it is a bit unclear if this sword
is a black blade, since it is never mentioned
and it is hard to tell from the manga or anime.
But I wouldn’t be surprised if it was, because
of the many titanic battles Roger fought during
his life.
And who did Roger fight in many of those epic
clashes?
That would be the former world’s strongest
man, Whitebeard, with his world famous naginata,
Murakumogiri.
While this is the only non-sword in this ranking,
it is undeniably one of the strongest blades
ever forged.
Of course it is a Supreme grade blade, just
like his rival’s sword, and Whitebeard masterfully
used Murakumogiri in combination with his
tremor devil fruit to produce attacks capable
of shattering islands.
Now let’s move from the strongest blades
of the previous generation into the top 3
which are all still being used in the story
today.
And how do you think the top three will turn
out?
Let’s kick it off with Gryphon, the faithful
blade of the one armed swordsman, Shanks.
And even today there’s a lot of mystery
surrounding this sword, but there’s also
some surprising information that was recently
revealed.
Like, did you know that Shanks can coat this
sword in a fiery aura?
I’m not sure if that means haki or some
other elemental powers, but damn I can’t
wait to see it.
And you also may not have realized that Shanks
did not actually start the story with this
sword.
In chapter 1 Shanks uses a sword with this
handguard which is distinctly different from
Gryphon.
This could mean that Oda just didn’t have
the final design in mind during chapter 1
or maybe Shanks obtained Gryphon sometime
in the years between chapter 1 and when we
first see him with Gryphon in chapter 234.
We also don’t know the official in-world
ranking for Gryphon, but it would not surprise
me at all to learn that it is a Supreme Grade
sword considering Shanks uses it basically
anytime he makes a move in the story .
Then with Gryphon out of the way, at number
two we have Enma, AND, in a bit of a twist,
its sibling blade, Ame no Habakiri.
Now I’m putting these two together because
they should essentially be on the same level
since they were both used by the former Samurai
Oden.
But since we have the most experience with
Enma, let’s discuss it in detail.
And we learn just how monstrous this sword
is right after Zoro traded Shusui for it.
By just holding the sword, Enma will suck
the life force out of you which can literally
kill you if you aren’t even strong enough.
This makes Zoro his haki so that he can fully
control the blade and use it to its full potential.
Hell, it basically forced Zoro to learn advanced
Conqueror’s haki during his final battle
against Kaido’s right hand man.
Plus Zoro used Enma, plus his other two swords
to block one of the strongest attacks we have
seen in the entire series . And while it is
currently ranked as a Great Grade blade, we
are told that if Zoro is able to turn Enma
into a black blade, then it would probably
be considered one of the Supreme grade blades.
Which the same could probably be said of Ame
no Habakiri.
Unfortunately, that sword is not being used
by someone as strong as Zoro at this time.
And now let’s reveal the single strongest
blade in the entire story.
No surprises here.
It is of course the blade of the strongest
swordsman in the world, Yoru.
Let’s go through the massive list of feats
this blade has.
It is the only blade in the series that has
both a Supreme Grade rank and is a Black Blade.
It is insanely massive and can cut through
giant ice mountains with ease.
It delivered the first real defeat of a straw
hat in the entire story and showed us just
how underleveled Luffy and Zoro were at the
time.
It has been used in many legendary duels with
Shanks throughout the years.
That is undoubtedly an impressive list of
accomplishments.
But wait!
There’s even more mystery surrounding this
sword.
One thing you may not have ever noticed are
these strange markings on Yoru ? Well, these
markings are actually shockingly similar to
the markings that are on the Empty Throne
in Mary Geoise.
I mean, what???
When I first saw this, it completely blew
my mind.
I thought he might have worked for the Celestial
dragons or maybe he took Yoru from someone
who did.
But whatever the answer is, there’s obviously
many more secrets this legendary sword might
hold about the One Piece World.
But as we get closer to the end of the story,
more of these secrets are being revealed,
and one of the most important secrets is the
truth about devil fruits.
So if you want to find out which of the MOST
INCREDIBLE devil fruits almost broke One Piece,
you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for Watching